I feel like when you undertake any big
task you kind of have this crisis of
faith in yourself and you're like I
can't do it it's um I couldn't like I
just can't I was living on my own in a
new city where I had never met anyone
two-hour flight away from anyone I knew
and I had no money and I was like just
trying to find couches to sleep on at
that point
I guess when anyone asks me like what
should I do I'm just like just do
anything anything will lead to something
else and and you just got to get out
there and take a chance need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe nation
what's up at 7:00 my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I wanna
see exploded onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a woman who went
from growing up on a farm and working
three jobs simultaneously while she was
16 to landing a breakthrough role on the
wolf of Wall Street and being one of
Hollywood's hottest actresses she's
Margot Robbie and here's my take on her
top ten rose to success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one overcome fear I feel like
when you undertake any big task you kind
of have this crisis of faith in yourself
and you're like I can't do it it's if I
couldn't like I just can't so I had that
and and for you know for a brief moment
I was like I guess I'm not gonna do the
role I I can't do nudity and I can't I
would never be good enough for this
anyway and and then you know the thought
occurred to me oh I guess who's gonna
play it then and then that just
infuriated me the thought of someone
else playing my role I was like well
they couldn't possibly do the role no I
have to do it because no one else could
possibly do the role so so yes now I had
my moment of my crisis of faith rule
number two persevere and did you realize
that neighbors was a springboard it took
a couple months to like reel I mean I
was 17 at the time I just finished high
school two months earlier and I'm now
living in Melbourne I mean I was playing
catch up really quickly anyway I was
living on my own in a new city where I
had never met anyone two hour flight
away from anyone I knew and I had no
money and I was like just trying to find
couches to sleep on at that point plus
before you're 18 you can't like sign up
and get electricity bills and stuff like
that so no one would rent a place to me
I didn't have any money the whole thing
was like I was just trying to like keep
my head above water at that point and
then once it settled in and I kind of
got settled there and you know it's
working constantly then that's when I
felt like oh yeah I've seen I've seen
people make the jump from here to
America so my choices are either stay on
you know be good enough to stay on this
show for decades the way some cast
members have which you know you'd have a
lovely life in Melbourne or you screw it
up and get fired which I didn't
obviously didn't want to take that
option or try and make the transition to
the American industry you know try and
move to LA and do pilot season as I had
seen a few customers do at that point so
that is my goal any fear when you made
the made the flight yes but it wasn't as
scary yes definitely but it wasn't as
scary
that first move to Melbourne that first
move to Melbourne was terrifying
because I was just you know I like I
said I didn't have money at the time I
didn't like heaven I didn't know when
you least when I moved to LA like when I
did that flight to LA I knew two people
there already who had already been our
neighbors and I had my money saved so if
anything went really wrong I knew I
could afford to get in a cab drive to
the airport and buy a ticket home and so
like I that's all I needed to know I was
like cool I'm sweet whatever happens
like if anything goes really wrong
I can always afford to fly hard and
they'll be fine and it ever once you got
here did ever seem like anything was
going really longer yeah there's
obviously like the ups and downs and
like the crazy as anyone who's moved to
a new city before I'm sure they've had
crazy experiences so I had all that for
sure but but no it's fine I was uh it
would have had to take a lot to make me
fly home I was like I will not be a
failure I came here I'm not going home
until I've made it in this business so
rule number three follow your instinct
when you kind of arrived on set you have
this amazing confidence I'd call you
boss eNOS northern ya know the thing
about Margo she is absolutely certain of
who she wants to be and what she wants
to do but she's absolutely certain of
who she wants you to be and what she
wants you to do too so that was that was
that was fun in the series she would say
no not like deucey I'm sorry hold it one
second do it no like you know I made a
couple movies Margo okay
I have some ideas too I think you fight
like that no you know what's great she's
she's right most of the time which is
fantastic right you know ninety percent
of the time if something doesn't feel
right to her in a scene it's it's
correct you know but but I'm a man I
gotta go against it anyway but she her
instincts are really brilliant you know
she can't always she can't always say
why it doesn't feel right she just says
just oh just do it the way I said you
know so I just learned to do that but it
was it was a was really really fun
working with someone with that level of
instincts that was so different than my
own rule number four my personal
favorite be prepared
how do you prepare for a role generally
like for I Tania obviously you had to
learn to ice skate and yeah was that
part of the appeal of the role was that
you would have to dive in and learn this
or was it sort of the thing you had to
do in order to play the part you know I
get excited with every character when
there's a skill set you get to learn for
it and we get like I'm so lucky and
spoil in that they get someone really
good to teach you how to do it to her so
it's nice like when I did focus I had a
real-life pickpocket teach me how to
pickpocket like I was like this is
exciting
Jokke buckets No so that was exciting
but the the I mean that's that's
mechanical preparation that just you
know you put the hours in and it pays
off but beyond that I am kind of like a
crazy person when I prep I do i do
timelines and backstories and I work
with a dialect coach and a movement
coach and an acting coach and I just
yeah I need to do a lot before I show up
to certain so I can throw it all out the
window when I get on set but but if I
hadn't done all the work beforehand I
would just be too scared to did you
watch a lot of footage of Tonya Harding
and I've watched every single piece of
footage there's on her hello a thousand
times over and I would had a voice in my
ipod I'd go to sleep listening to I mean
I like lived in Tanya Lane for for a
long time rule number five seize your
opportunities what was actually your
first job in the business when you sort
of knew you wanted to be an actor best
job in America or Festo just as an
actress yeah it was this indie film
short on the Gold Coast which is where
I'm from in Australia and it never got
released or I've never even seen it like
it was very very low budget like lower
than an indie film but more like a
student film sort of thing but it was a
thriller sort of thing called I see you
do you worry it's not worry but do you
expect it to come out any day now
but it was a chance to be on a film set
no matter how small the set was it was
still film set and that was like a dream
come true rule number six do everything
I haven't actually been given a piece of
advice that I can recall right now but I
guess when anyone asks me like what
should I do I'm just like just do
anything anything will lead to something
else and you just got to get out there
and take a chance even if it's unpaid
work whatever it is it will lead to
something better so do everything yep do
it all rule number seven immerse
yourself in what you do I had never seen
this film is a love story and then
Sebastian kind of played Jeff in such a
way that it kind of became a really
weird love story we got so carried away
that I genuinely forgotten that we were
in a film set and that I wasn't Tanja
and that he wasn't Jeff and we got into
this massive fight do you remember this
it's not in the film it didn't make the
cut because it's a bit intense but we
got in this massive fight waiting slams
my hand into the door and we got into
like a brawl and essentially I ended up
storming off down the street which was
like the end of the set like it would
have been just the road in the real
world and you were coming off to me
through where are you going and I think
you even said magar and then I was like
I'm going to the hospital gonna hurt my
hand and it was so ridiculous and I was
so caught up in it and then I think I
punched you in the side of the head when
you picked me up anyway it was all crazy
old world and and that ended up being my
favorite scene because I forgot that I
was acting completely and I forgot we're
on a film set and nothing makes me like
more exhilarated when when I genuinely
forget that I forget where I am rule
number eight control your fate you've
got a production company man your
husband and friends now yes obviously
with the me to movement and with so much
of that going on in Hollywood at the
moment to see a woman producing her own
film and starting her own production
company and sort of operating stuff from
behind the scenes as well as being on
camera is really really lovely for the
rest of us I'm good I'm glad that part
of the decision at all where was it just
some it was I mean the point of the
company was to promote when
in films whether that be the female
protagonist north female led content or
through female storytellers I think if
we want to see an change in this
industry we have to have more women in
positions of power and that's when
things will really change and you'll get
a lot more authentic version of a female
story sometimes not always though Craig
told the story we were brilliantly and
I've worked with quite a few directors
male directors who tell female stories
wonderfully because they don't see it as
a male female story they see them as
people but no it was definitely the
driving force behind our company to
promote women in film and also a chance
for me to kind of control my fate a
little more and take matters into your
own hands a little bit
rule number nine stand up for yourself
how do you handle conflict when it
arises I avoid conflict at all costs and
I haven't worked with an actor that I've
despised but I have worked with someone
on the production side who I didn't
appreciate the way they spoke about me
in front of groups so it took me a
couple months but then eventually I
plucked up the courage and pulled him
aside and said you know you're
discrediting what I do when you speak to
me like that and he was really great
about it and rule number ten the last
one before some very special bonus clips
have fun I had always planned on having
a 24-hour party on my 24th birthday and
we did that and it was here in London
actually and it was just brilliant it
was so much fun
and every time did you start we started
at 9 a.m. and we went till 9 a.m. so we
started in our courtyard where I live
with all my flatmates and there we had
like a champagne breakfast and then we
moved to a different location and
different location went to Hyde Park and
then moved to like this bar and then we
moved to another bar and and we had
costumes you had to change the costumes
the whole way along and then we went
full circle and ended up popping a
bottle of champagne again at 9:00 a.m.
and the courtyard and did anybody bail
or they were there for the whole I I've
had really stern words with everyone I
was like if anyone bails and doesn't
make the 24 hours be dead to me we all
looked wonderful
now I've got three very special Margot
Robbie clips around going all-out
focusing and going with the flow before
that commitment of the day time you just
watch this amazing video you learned a
bunch of lessons how are you going to
apply it to your life or to your
business what did you learn that you're
committing to making a change right now
leave it down in the comments below I
want to see what you have to say thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clips
and it's not just with like doing a
naked scene but any scene where you feel
like you're gonna make a fool of
yourself
I just say like you gotta go all out let
you need to fully commit to this because
if you have acid it will look so stupid
but if you do it with complete
conviction oftentimes you can put it off
so just try to do with a total
conviction I like yeah I'm a fairly
impatient person so I like to work a lot
and I like to work fast but I don't like
overlapping projects and I've done a bit
of that this year where you know we're
still juggling you know in doing press
for one film whilst filming about the
film whilst doing the ADR for another
film you know and I kind of like to
stick to one character for a finite
amount of time and then let it go and
move on to the next one but they see it
as being a bit of overlap and juggling
and it's a bit like yeah
yeah this job's it's a very like fluid
sort of lifestyle you're never really in
one spot you're always moving around
you're always working on different
projects different characters it's
really hard to set yourself these little
boundaries and rules because they just
end up being thrown out the window
anyway I mean I try and be like I'm
gonna keep my personal life and my work
life separate it's impossible like I
can't like I work with my best friend's
work and personal already into mix so as
far as like how to set boundaries with
with public persona I suppose oh yeah I
don't know I guess kind of just go with
the flow and try and do it by a
case-by-case basis
[Music]
poor work ever if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]